you know we've got some problems in this
country you know we've got a president
who
doesn't seem like he's all there
we have people who don't believe in math
we have other people who believe you can
endlessly print money we have people who
believe the borders should be open we
have people who believe that boys are
girls and girls or boys we have people
who believe that non-racism is racism
and we also have people who just flat
out don't understand anything about
anything that would be the generous
version and the more cynical version
would be that they want to destroy the
whole damn thing here's nancy pelosi
but
we cannot allow the fossil fuel industry
to use this as an excuse to reverse
everything we're doing to save the
planet
one of the things i think that the
president may say i don't have this as a
fact is that we will use the
defense production act to
speed up uh
diversification
uh so that we're not so dependent
on oil
okay if you believe that that alcoholic
geriatric buffoon is up to the task of
saving the planet then i'd like to sell
you a bridge um you can really see
what's going on here we now have this
crisis this war in ukraine
no excuses for what russia has done you
cannot invade a sovereign nation and
just start killing innocent people
but because of this over the last say
month and a half or so and it really
started a little bit before because we
had a slow-motion entry into the war
remember for weeks biden kept saying
well i think putin's going to do it and
i gave him a list of things he can't do
and maybe he's going to do this or that
and you know in two days i'm pretty sure
it's going to happen
um
you can see what this is really about
and what this really seemingly about is
about at this point is crashing the
american economy and ushering in this
green new deal and getting us off gas
and oil and fossil fuels and all those
things which coincidentally is exactly
what these people have wanted to do the
entire time so
look even if
even if you hate fossil fuels and and if
you really hate fossil fuels there's a
lot of things in your life you shouldn't
be doing okay and petroleums and pretty
much everything in your house and your
clothes and all of that stuff but even
if you absolutely hate fossil fuels and
even if you absolutely believe greta
thunder when it comes to climate change
and all of those things the idea that
these people are competent enough to
actually transition us off properly from
the the fuel literally the fuel that has
been fueling the economy and our culture
and our civilization for a hundred plus
years really more than that uh to their
green new deal
to their idea of all renewable energy
and that is what will keep us safe and
everything else that they're competent
enough to do that is really really crazy
but they're now telling you that that
really is what this is all about what
does a government do a government never
lets a good crisis go to waste and
they're going oh we've got a war over
there so we are going to figure out how
to usher in all the nonsense that we
want to do here but we've got gay pete
and i always i only call him gay pete
because the only reason he has the job
as transportation secretary is because
he's gay that's not just something i'm
saying that's what biden said you know
we've got the first openly gay
transportation secretary we've got the
first openly trans health secretary
deputy something something uh having
nothing to do with his qualifications
because obviously he's not qualified he
was the mayor of south bend indiana
that's pretty much all he's ever done
and that's a perfectly fine job i
suppose but he knows nothing about
transportation but he's ushering in an
era of equity and all sorts of stuff and
he really wants you to get rid of your
car our country was better positioned to
handle it than many others so less
dependent on foreign oil and that
protects us from shortages at fuel
stations but here's the thing to
remember even if all of the oil we use
in the usa were made in the usa the
price of it is still subject to powers
and dynamics outside of the usa which
means that until we achieve a form of
energy independence that is based on
clean energy created here at home
american citizens will still be
vulnerable to wild price hikes
no lie lie complete lie pete what are
you talking about even if all of our
energy was made here at home so all of
our oil and energy was made on we'd
still be subject to wild price acts
no we wouldn't because we have plenty of
energy here we just have not unleashed
it properly
and it wouldn't be if we were energy
independent right something that there
was that orange guy always forget his
name that he wanted to do then we
wouldn't be so dependent so that if
russia invades ukraine we wouldn't see
these crazy spikes so that's a complete
lie but then even furthers the lie and
this is what they do with everything
they lie about everything and then they
lie about that his next statement is in
essence we just have to get to clean
energy and if we can just have clean
energy then we won't be reliant on these
spikes but what are you talking about if
if we have full
oil energy energy independence
regardless of whether it's fossil fuels
or whether it's clean energy
what's the difference if we can do it
all ourselves then why would clean
energy not have anything to do
with the spikes right they just
lie about everything but again this is
the plan so you've got pelosi saying you
better let us do what we want to do
because we got to save the planet then
you have pete just flat out lying just
lying about energy independence and
really then at the end telling you what
he wants to do it's not about energy
independence it's about moving us all to
electric okay and by the way uh the joe
biden fella the man pretending to be
president he's very excited because he
might be able to save you uh eighty
dollars a month
under my plan
which is before the congress now we can
take advantage of the next generation of
electric vehicles
that a typical driver will save about
eighty dollars a month
from not having to pay gas at the pump
congrats everybody
you're going to save eighty dollars a
month of course you're gonna have to buy
an electric car and even with whatever
subsidies the government might give you
might is the key part there uh electric
cars still cost way more uh joe i don't
know if you know this but a lot of
people are hurting economically right
now okay so uh you know they're not
looking to get electric cars you know if
you can get say a regular sedan you know
you can get a very sort of basic simple
sedan for i don't know 14 000 bucks you
can though they exist right um you know
you have to spend at least at least 50
000 on an electric vehicle so
what are we talking about here joe are
you saying that these people have to
take out huge loans forever i thought
you guys don't like loans either because
you don't like interest or math doesn't
work or something so what actually are
you saying that you can save 80 of
course this is the same guy who tweeted
out on july 4th that the average
american was going to save 16 cents on
their july 4th picnic so
yeah i think you get i think you get the
point